Just a moment ago tonight, Elon Musk,
in an interview with Andrew Ross
Sorkin at The New York Times
DealBook summit,
saying this to advertisers
who've left X over
his endorsement of anti-Semitic content.
If somebody tried to blackmail me
with advertising, blackmail with money
yourself,
but
go yourself.
Is that clear?
I hope it is.
Seems pretty clear.
OUTFRONT now, Dana Hull, Bloomberg
senior reporter who covers Elon Musk.
So, Dana, The New York Times
reporting that this anti-Semitic post
could possibly cost up to $75 million
in lost ad revenue this year.
Meantime, Musk is warning
that the advertising boycott
could kill the company.
He's not happy about it.
It's fascinating for him to say that,
of course,
based on why the boycott happened.
Yeah, I mean, I think
what you saw tonight at the DealBook
summit was authentic musk.
I mean, he's angry about it,
but he's not going to change his tune
and he's not going to change the way
he operates
just because advertisers
are leaving the platform
and, you know,
dropping F-bombs at a big summit
like DealBook is unusual for a CEO.
But as we all know by now,
Elon Musk
is not your typical CEO
by any stretch of the imagination.
No, certainly not that that is true.
You know,
he also talked about his recent trip
to Israel, saying it was planned
before the fallout,
that it wasn't an apology tour.
He did apologize, though, for the Post
saying that of all the things
he's written on it,
it was the most foolish thing
he'd ever said on the platform,
likening it
to handing a loaded gun
to those who hate me
and arguably to those
who are anti-Semitic
and saying he was quite sorry.
It wasn't his intention.
Is this just trying to save face
or is that actually genuine?
You know, I think it's a mixture of both.
I mean, we finally get this sort of quasi
apology, what,
two weeks after the initial posts
that is still up on the platform.
It has not been deleted.
And, you know,
I think that Musk is not always the most
emotionally intelligent person.
He's not always the best
reader of the room.
He tends to sort of shoot from the hip
and say things without a filter.
And that can backfire,
which we've seen kind of
throughout his career.
But he you know,
this was the closest
that we've seen him
come to
expressing regret and remorse
for the way that his words
were construed.
I mean,
you know, some advice would be
maybe not tweet or not post,
but he's obviously
the owner of the platform
and that's his prerogative.
I don't know that
that was going to get through,
especially because
of what we saw yesterday. Right.
Supporting this Pizzagate
long debunked conspiracy theory.
But could supporting that as well?
There are so many of these moments
when you add them all up.
I mean, it does raise a question is
what is the future of X at this point,
especially with advertisers
are saying in the
numbers that we're seeing,
I, I think that
Musk is
really trying
to pivot to a subscription model
where he wants creators and people
who, you know, want to be on X to pay
for different levels of access.
And he does not want to be beholden
to advertisers.
And this is sort of a
I mean, the wild irony here is that,
you know, Musk created
Tesla, this incredible force
in the automotive industry,
without relying on advertising at all.
And then he bought
this social media company
that is heavily dependent on advertising.
And I think that that's
sort of a circle that he can't square.
Yeah,
listen, there is
there's a lot there,
and I'm glad that you're watching it
so intently
because you can translate
a lot of it for me.
Danielle, thank you
for being with us tonight.